hi there local bank robber and cosplay
enthusiasts Godzilla Mendoza here let's
make a black suit I guess you can read
the tile you know the [ __ ] videos
best letter man suit is normally read
but sometimes it's not read this is the
time when it's not read because he has a
space parasite in his blood sucking
adrenaline out of him and slowly killing
him her name's Mary and I'm making it I
guess how hard could that be okay so you
make the mask pretty much how I already
did in that other video go watch that to
learn how to make the mask
done okay good so you do it like that
man what am I doing with my life making
YouTube videos I should have just quit
halfway through and settled for being a
bank robber anyway in case you didn't go
to that other video because YouTube took
out annotations and I can't figure out
the end card I'll just repeat myself I
didn't get the cat goggles this time
because I wanted the eyes to look a
little bit more squinty and angry I got
these spider-man sunglasses from the
store and had my mom do the [ __ ] with
the dremel tool because I'm tired of
making things by myself and she's less
likely to [ __ ] it up and make the eyes
uneven so whatever you glue the lenses
on with the fabric glue and then run
some stitches through the holes you
drilled so they don't come off because
both the glue and the stitches are
enough to keep it in if either of them
gives out
then you make sure to filter out the
larger chunks of flour with a fork when
adding it to the green chilli which
should have been on the stove for at
least 15 minutes prior to make sure that
the pork is cooked thoroughly
the chee-chaw tones should also be
seasoned at least three times I usually
have a preference of four to make it
spicier some folks like to salt the
French fries before it all goes into the
oven but I found that you can achieve
the same effect by salting them
afterward I also find that the party
suits you get at Party City are really
easy to use for these projects and
they're not too expensive the next step
after that is to mark the places on your
body where you want the logo to go with
the help of your black uncle look I have
black family members I can make fun of
my love all I want it's fine I'm not
racist you're racist and fine until
Brees occurs yeah black people
oh god I am just the worst
then take the suit off after measuring
Hey look I'm spider-man Rain spider-man
after that I had my uncle who happens to
be the lead singer of Bloc Party help me
create a stencil to put the logo on the
suit
you can freehand it with some puff paint
or cut it out of some white fabric and
awkwardly sew it on with your mom's
shitty sewing machine I decided to use
fabric paint so you print out the
stencil after figuring out which version
of the logo to use because there's quite
a few cool ones then you decide to
browse Twitter for a moment and see that
Amy Pascal says spider-man won't be in
the MCU soon react accordingly
Oh dad are you okay are you okay okay
are we going to watch The Simpsons
hey kid what are you doing ah Danny pass
cow damn yeah this is supposed to be a
tragic announcement but your reaction is
super funny
ah why God why have you abandoned us
Kevin stop it you'll excuse me money to
stop it oh I'm going to kill any Pascal
I'm going to kill Kevin Pete and I'm
gonna kill myself again
there is my Dean's I'm really sad
because I like this pair of jeans you
know what I like more than this pair of
jeans
I don't spider-man okay look watch them
students like gentle mindful anyway I
wish my camera was as good as David then
your uncle draws a grid pattern over the
piece of paper and then copies the grid
on a piece of poster board and then
draws every individual square to size is
that really long and time-consuming yes
that means you basically get the same
image but twice the size yeah well
they're streaming it on April full day
nowhere else after you have the stencil
drawn out don't forget to season the
chorizo with pepper red pepper and a
dash of salt if you're into that sort of
thing you naughty girl
moving forward you can use an exacto
knife to cut out the shape of the spider
logo on your kitchen floor while your
family walks by and judges you it's very
important that you lay on top of it
because your back hurts and get your
face as close to the blade as possible
that way you could really see what
you're doing and carve out those fine
details as accurately as you can
don't forget proper knife etiquette
where you always cut towards yourself
because the adrenaline from the fear of
being stabbed will cause you to focus
more and get the lines more precise on
that stencil then stuff some cardboard
inside the suits to block the paint from
bleeding through to the other side use
some pins to get the stencil attached to
the suit properly and make sure it's
really flush with the surface of the
fabric no gaps or else it'll look dumb
step 19 alternatively you could also go
to your laptop that was bought with your
parents hard earned money and open up
the porn finder and type in spider-man
black suit in the shopping tab then buy
that $300 one with your parents as
hard-earned money
freeloader also don't type in black
spider-man suit because then you'll just
get images of that character who's on
going to keep getting canceled but we
still need to keep in mind for some
reason thanks Brian
that paints going to take a while to dry
in the meantime let's take another break
to check out Twitter oh look my good
buddy Orion's comics was asking about
Doc Ock let's answer but then suddenly a
wild slot appears to refute my claims
how do I know he's evil well uh Dan it
appears that auto is in a hydra costume
surrounded by Hydra guys doing the hail
Hydra thing and Hydra is a terrorist
organization that wants to take over the
world and was founded by literal Nazis
that and he appears to be slamming an
injured spider-man into the ground with
his morally righteous additional wind I
think it's a fair assumption that he's a
bad guy again to recap Nazi
supervillains attacking the protagonist
wait what's this it appears mr. slot
deleted his response well Dan you sure
showed me I'll never criticize you again
now go back to riding your directionless
politically-charged Doc Ock fan fiction
that will inevitably be read conned out
of existence in ten years by a better
writer
ciao alright the paint's been drying
overnight so spy goodbye now right ah
close enough maybe if I just uh hey wait
a second let me try something
ah okay turns out white paint on black
fabric just says [ __ ] you and turn
silver don't be a pain being take that
crap use this these are paint markers
they're meant for drawing on drywall
there you go white is right now you
don't look like Topher Grace Venom and
skinny cracker now flip it over and try
again except the stencil is a gooey mess
and can't be used again so just put on
some masking tape there's something
alright now to put it on and and OH
Oh God Oh God the cardboard inside
became glued to the paint because there
were too many layers I can't remove all
the itch paper on the inside I was too
worried about how the logo would fit
horizontally I never stopped
think about how the suit stretches
vertically when worn spider is
practically on my crotch now it's
ruining too much paint on the zipper I
can barely put it on and take it off
it's just scratching it really inside
there's no way now it's all gone
Wow they stopped being an instructional
video and is now just a documentary of
my failures okay buy a new suit this
brand called second skin is way better
actually everything fits well the suit
feels more comfortable and it has this
smooth and sleek texture to it [ __ ] glad
I say this component it appears that the
suit needs to stretch a certain way
before you paint it you can't just lay
it down flat and go to town with some
markers or something I'd suggest buying
a mannequin but I have no idea where to
get one of those for the cheap so I
guess I just got to wear it while it's
being painted new plan I'll make a
flexible stencil that can shape around
my body with masking tape cut the spider
logo out of the tape with the sticky
side up and then wrap the tape around
yourself then lay down some towels and
get to work if I ever become an actor at
least I'll be ready for the makeup chair
this can take a while and won't exactly
be comfortable do your best Rebecca
remain impression oh hey yeah hair
dryers are a thing that exists use one
of those don't go too heavy with the
fabric paint it'll glue the zipper to
itself okay done wait you still want the
legs on the front and back to connect Oh
fine mark some lines with a silver
sharpie and connect each leg to the
other then use some masking tape to
shape each one probably less risky to
just paint each leg individually then do
the gloves with the same process I guess
easy all right now sacrifices have to be
made so bear in mind that the paint will
bleed through the fabric and stay stuck
to your skin I have taken seven showers
and it's still there finally
what should have taken only an afternoon
to make is now a month-long project
this video could have been 2 minutes but
everything had to go wrong
why am I always getting the short end
what's happening to me today
first I make a bunch of racially
insensitive jokes and then I call my
audience a bunch of freeloaders and then
I take the time to yell at games a lot
on Twitter these aren't things I would
do normally probably most of the time
well okay maybe the dance block thing
but like the other two not really
the most part not like all the time
anchor building lightly so much hey my
usual meek and upbeat charm has been
replaced by a sullen bitterness and
biting sarcasm with causing this
wait this whole video has been super
edgy and angry but why could be no no
there's no way it couldn't be
perhaps it's it's this suit it's been
such a pain in the ass to make it's
making me more why would I ever take it
off that's group of hilarious
and just laughter God speed up too big
for his bed nothing seems to fit the
of all and all my head they keep falling